uh i have to ask before i leave i've  seen photos of you rollerblading wearing  a lot of neon i'm not sure what  photos you're referring to i'm required  to get a quote about that before i leave  the room  in neon and rollerblading i would  remember  seemed like a dream i was having or kind  of like that  that nightmare where you're naked at  school you know except  it wasn't school and it was the world  and it wasn't a dream it was real  what required more time in the gym but  like getting ready for this role and all  the physical scenes or or that role  being ken  huh very different  very different roles ken and the gray  man although i do think that the gray  man would be ken's favorite movie  but uh you know they both required uh  very different uh you know very  different  things but that was what part of the fun  of going back and forth between the two  you know  working different muscles literally  right  you